everyone's focused on hey I was going to
take your job let me just remind you
when 80 of the world were working on
farms and the tractor was invented all
the media back then was saying these
tractors are going to take your job and
this is the worst thing that happened we
demonized the invention of the tractor
because what we're very good at is
demonizing new technology without
understanding the capacity of humans
just to give you the preview of what
happened with the tractor the tractor
was invented it made us way more
efficient and allowed millions and
millions and millions of people to stop
working on farms and do other that
was bigger nobody cried for the people
that sold the Yellow Pages there was 40
000 people selling the Yellow Pages when
Google and Yahoo came out and put them
out of business you didn't cry when the
iPhone came and put a ton of businesses
out you liked that you had the iPhone AI
is about to come along will it affect
some people of course but people will
adjust because we always do